[Musique]
oui
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
oh
[Rires]
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
oh
[Musique]
chers amis téléspectateurs bonjour 215e
jours de survie après ce que l'on a
appelé l'explosion du siècle ne perdez
pas courage et du fond de votre abri
répéter avec nous aujourd'hui irradié
demain radio quelques nouvelles du front
les villes d'orange et de salon sans
tomber hier soir après des combats
désespérés mais ne pardonne pas quoi et
pour s'orienter appel moral
nous allons retrouver chantal qui va
nous aider le temps de ce week end est
bien ou pas de météo journée pour les
villes de cannes et saint-raphaël qui
ont été rayés de la carte
hier soir par contre pour la journée une
surprise en effet nous attendions à
moins 50 degrés
et nous aurons au moins 45 degrés cela
grâce à un couloir de fumée provoquée
par l'explosion des forages du sud c'est
donc une excellente nouvelle
en revanche les pluies radioactives
intégration nos régions
non pas mercredi mais je dis sachez vous
protéger le soleil aujourd'hui se lavera
à 16h20 mariera juste
les autres 48 profiter au maximum et
nous souhaitons une très très bonne foi
de tous les marseillais amoureux d'elle
le monde
[Applaudissements]
est ce que nous en temps on vous aime
tarn et vous
[Applaudissements]
jason bourne mais est-ce que vous
vous invitez réellement franchement d
je ne vous entends pas mais ce que vous
m'entendez est ce que vous entendez
[Applaudissements]
dupau a mis à votre disposition pour une
somme modique des abris anti atomiques à
la première alerte
ayez le réflexe de pau
habitant de la région d'aix-en-provence
ce n'est pas le bombardement aérien hier
soir qui vous a irradié
mais bien l'explosion de la centrale
nucléaire de garrigue louer les
responsables de la sécurité doit sur en
nous disant que ce type d'accident ne
peut pas se reproduire dans les autres
centres mais mon dieu que le temps passe
lui et puis le temps passe et nous
allons la retrouver chantal chantal qui
est sur le terrain pour notre jeu le jeu
que nous attendons tous le jeu du
survivant
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
tous
gageure de vous retrouver pour notre jeu
du sourire en bourse m brasse et
évidemment nous devons nous trouver dans
une ville qui était attentes et une vers
moi de deux jours au chercheur retrouver
les survivants
y en aura-t-il je ne sais pas en tout
cas je voudrais signaler à l'heureux
gagnant qu'il bénéficiera d'un voyage
paris-tokyo offertes par notre chaîne
évidemment et il paraît une compagnie
d'aviation force est là dedans tout
heureux le nom pour parra publicité y at
il des survivants aujourd'hui nous avons
savoir tout de suite sur beugnot je vais
les appeler y at il des survivants ou
par toute autre branche sur paris
j'ai aperçu un survivant givet
[Musique]
bonjour monsieur survivants la taxe n'a
pas été trop dur
tout va bien je l'amène oui je connais
déjà dix survivants des génomes version
évidemment mettre sur la cuisine vont
faire du velouté de canard aux pêches il
faut évidemment un canard et des pêches
mais il faut aussi la roma très
particulière et exotique laquelle oui le
balsillie non monsieur je vous donne
encore une chance réfléchissez mon pouce
du renfort bravo monsieur s'il faut
évidemment du canard et des pêches il
faut aussi un clou de girofle ou l'impôt
monsieur vous connaissez évidemment
notre épreuve facultative qui vous donne
trois chiffres
leucate pour gagner le voyage paris
tokyo le 6 pour gagner la voiture et les
huit pour gagner à cocotte-minute cas
choisissez vous monsieur je prends la
voiture numéro 6 ne prenez pas trop de
risques alors le 6 pour la boîte à
alléger monsieur je vous en remercie
[Applaudissements]
ouah
la bonne chance effectivement ce sont
des choses qui arrivent dans notre grand
jeu là je me dépêchais de vous rendre
l'antenne parce que j'entends les
bombardiers à nouveau sur la ville
alors écoutez on se retrouve tout à
l'heure si vous le voulez bien pour la
suite de notre grand jeu des survivants
à tout à l'heure
et maintenant quelques instants de
détente avec la grande saga d'avant le
grand boum
voici la dynastie des qing
[Musique]
je chantais
m
pour fasciner l'armée d'agir qui me
désole
je joue
c'est des tickets d'alimentation vous en
avez assez des rations de nourriture que
l'armée vous distribuer tous les jours
et je vous comprends
edwige que dean auriez vous ce soir si
vous en aviez totalement le loisir et
bien charles henry je ferais exactement
la même chose qu hier mais je dînerai
vous
avec des cadres
de vodka dans un nid de glace moi je
ferais plutôt pour du saumon de la
baltique avec un magret de canard du du
périgord je vous connais bien la gobbi
mer bourg b surtout que vous n'êtes vous
pas tenté par ses plats de rêve en ces
périodes de fêtes qui approchent une
race
si vous voulez vous les procurer on peut
les parachutages et des prix seront
consentis
[Applaudissements]
demandez lui mon général quels types de
bombes d'ambert
quel type de bande à les emporter quel
type nos kits de bandas les autorités
[Musique]
vous devrez cockpit et regarder alors le
temps et la relance alors comme au poker
en général ce sont des ce sont des
ogives nucléaires
c'est bon c'est comme rentrer à la base
tout de suite demandé pour un peu la
base de suite et bien chambéry
téléspectateurs voici la seconde partie
de notre grève de le jeu du survivant au
jeu si vous êtes très nombreux à suivre
cette émission et je dois préciser quand
même ce n'est pas facile de trouver tout
le temps les candidats
là on juge par une végétation à mon avis
il s'agit d'une bombe à neutrons qui
explosent et par ici parce que
franchement il ne reste presque plus
rien mais ce n'est pas grave je ne
désespère pas je suis même persuadé
pouvait très rapidement de nouveaux
candidats pour participer à ce grand jeu
ce grand jeu qui je vous le rappelle
permet quand même à ceux qui participent
de gagner un voyage paris tokyo offertes
par notre chaîne une compagnie
d'aviation dont je tairai le nom pour
quoi faire publicité voilà donc
j'attends les survivants je ne pense
qu'il m j'entends du bruit
en voici deux bonjour messieurs les sur
mille mois quelle joie de vous voir
ses proches pensent que nous appelons
dans notre jargon une défaillance
technique n'est vraiment pas grave parce
que le jeu du survivant en a vu d'autres
qui va continuer évidemment il va
continuer dans pour continuer puisque
j'ai les deux candidats qui sont en
allant les cieux rapprocher pour vous
poser notre question messieurs commun at
il dit
[Musique]
à
[Applaudissements]
c'est quartier général on ne vous entend
pas des crimes en général quand on
entend pas on ne vous entend vous entend
pas
[Musique]
vous allez faire vous allez largué
vosges ive et rentrer à la base tout de
suite vous voulez
[Musique]
santé et hygiène de vie
on nous annonce que le sida est en très
nette régression le rhume de cerveau
aussi merci les chercheurs continuez vos
recherches
grâce à vous de la france grâce à vous
la france avance eh bien oui eh bien oui
bonsoir
n'oubliez pas votre rendez vous de
demain à n'oubliez pas non plus notre
devise
aujourd'hui irradiés demain radieux
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
[Musique]
cette semaine on n'avait pas bien le
moral mais rassurez vous la semaine
prochaine sera beaucoup mieux n'oubliez
pas pour autant d'autres devises
aujourd'hui radieux demain irradiés
[Musique]